françois mitterrand en allemagne de
l'est le président vient d'arriver il ya
quelques minutes à berlin est
le voici qui arrive donc à berlin trois
jours de visite officielle pour le
président français qui fera accompagner
sa compagne mitterrand pour trois jours
pour s'entretenir avec les nouveaux
dirigeants de rda et notamment avec le
chrono ministre en mode raw deux thèmes
majeurs pour cette visite officielle les
nouveaux rapports entre la france
l'europe et les pays de l'est mais aussi
deuxième thème l'éventuelle
réunification de l'allemagne
philippe rochot à berlin ce drapeau de
l'unité allemande slogan pour ou contre
la réunification nous sommes le peuple
une allemagne pour l'europe si slogan
françois mitterrand les entendra tout au
long de son voyage en rda de berlin est
à leipzig lighting la cité de la
contestation temps forts de son voyage
la ville aux quinze mille étudiants
la cité où l'église évangélique joue un
rôle militant et orchestre les
manifestations qui voit chaque lundi sur
cette place des filets deux cent à trois
cent mille personnes
derrière ce mouvement de leipzig
particulièrement disciplinés il y à un
homme courte masur chef d'orchestre
dirigeante un palais de la musique le
gewandhaus françois mitterrand le
rencontrera il se veut rassurant sur le
problème de la réunification allemande
les peuples des autres pays du monde ne
doivent plus avoir peur de nous les
allemands ont changé dans beaucoup de
domaines
ils ont appris à respecter ceux qui
vivent dans la liberté est ici
particulièrement rencontre avec grigor
ghisi le nouveau chef du pc est allemand
il prêche pour que l'unité européenne
soit réalisée avant que ne tombent les
frontières entre les deux allemagnes
sans quoi il y as danger des antennes
nous savons que le président mitterrand
attend aussi de sa visite en rd à la
construction d'un ordre de pays
européens et que leipzig a aussi une
signification profonde au centre de
l'europe
repas sera une grosse bataille nova les
accords bilatéraux qui seront signés ici
au conseil d'état permettront donc à la
rda de s'appuyer sur l'europe pour une
future confédération entre les deux
allemagnes